our geopolitical rivals have begun to
use everything
I do not want to offend anyone, but nevertheless
I will say they have begun to use everything that is bad
for their own purposes, they have started
brainwashing countries in the countries of the
post-Soviet space, and above
all in Ukraine, we have been undertaking
for decades I want to
emphasize this on  for decades, they have
been trying to build
relations in new geopolitical
conditions, but they have done everything in order
to set up in the new conditions not just
not just fraternal relations
and loans, they gave almost free
energy resources, it has been supplying for years,
nothing has worked, just nothing, we have
always and you know my position  the Ukrainian people have always been
considered a brotherly
people. I already think so now and now
then, and what is happening is, of course, a
tragedy, our common tragedy, but it is
not the result of our policy, but
rather it is the result of the
policies of other countries, of course,
military operations military operations are
all  yes, it is connected with the tragedy of the loss of
people, we are well aware of this, we are aware of
this, but since it is
inevitably better today than tomorrow,
and we will solve these problems without
prejudice to the development of the economy and the
social sphere without
not fulfilling any obligations
to our people before  our
citizens in the social field. We
will not engage in the militarization of the country and the
militarization of the economy, I have no doubt
that all the goals that we set for ourselves
will certainly be achieved
[applause]